this is a photograph of the ladies man
SEC yeah and it is fantastic and you can
see the audience loves it it's a tour of
the force it has a theatricality but
it's also very cinematic as well so not
only did you of course build this huge
set but you had to photograph it and you
had a special some a special equipment
made to photograph it this is this crane
tell us about what this is well I built
a set that was 44 feet high 65 feet wide
and I needed equipment to complement
that so I went to Chapman and I said
your biggest crane is too small for me
I need that size and we measured it off
and it was 58 feet or something and I
was on two sound stages I was on 15 and
16 in order to build that set and
because this set was so unusual and so
unique
I had sound in every room in the
ceilings in the ceilings I had all of
the mics Sennheiser's by the way Ben
thank you and and I had the mics there
and on the stage prior to getting to the
set you come over here and I've got four
mixers who are mixing all of the people
all over the set when they're talking in
room four they're waiting for the entry
of the girl coming from room six and
they all planned what was gonna happen
and I got great great sound here we have
a picture of the Mitchel BNC camera it
was a state of the art for the time but
there's something else on that camera it
looks like some video equipment so
what's going on your video assist is on
the left side of the camera and it would
be sitting in the same place that our
finder is and the only problem with the
video assist for me was I couldn't get
this close
I couldn't choke it
because if I was in seven feet I'm
getting a parallax problem so I would
stage everything so that didn't happen
and I was accommodating this new device
that I had created and thought it would
be very good and now today there isn't a
film that starts without the video
assist and I'm very happy about that cuz
I got the patent videotape didn't come
in until 1962 and I had just done the
bellboy 1960 and I had 14 monitors
spotted all over the set and I'm in the
scene with the other actors but with
this I I see that monitor when I look
over at him to do the scene with him I
see it with that monitor I got one back
here I got one all the way over there I
had everything that I could see and
commit to printing if I saw it and it
was good I'd print we have a footage of
a little bit later as it was refined
this was on three on a couch that shows
you on the set yeah call Manoogian
okay and here's Jerry's dozy toy so what
tell us what what Jerry's noisy toy is
when I wanted to give actors of feeling
for the scene and what it represented I
would help them by cueing a very very
low level music track which the
engineers at Paramount
well responsible for losing their hair
every time they heard my name but what I
did was almost impossible to conceive in
the mind of a technician you mean you
played a track that's not going to be in
it right right well I had to help
Sennheiser they came and had meetings
with me about what I wanted to do I
wanted to build a top ceiling element
that would take much of the sound and
the sides of it I'd be getting the sound
that I want